this guy is better than those guys and
the scouts seem to love everything they
see at elevis Levis that's what they
love that's an NFL arm right there and
that's a big completion of Barry and
brown who's starting to make a name for
himself the true freshman out of
Nashville Redskins gorilla called up
that play you set it up perfectly
partner but I tell you what that that's
a rifle like that that is such a only
one drive that went into Florida
territory
rides the play action has plenty of time
to crank it up and go down field
into the end zone perfect
[Applause]
let's see this catch does he secure it
wow how about the high point
that is definitely going to stand by
key his kimber's is draped all over him
oh does it touch the ground there on the
side difficult to see it didn't see that
initially from the first angle let's
take a peek let's see watch the ball
here watch the point of the ball their
left side of the thigh
of course the ball can touch the ground
but you have to maintain possession and
the ball cannot wobble whatsoever
upon contact with the ground
[Applause]
and it's really close
let's take a look left side
difficult to tell
exactly where it is right there
remember ruling on the field is a
touchdown by Keith let's bring in our
rules expert Matt Austin Matt
yeah Joe the key as Greg said is it did
the ball hit the ground through the
process he definitely has it up high he
takes a hand off it looks like it slides
down his leg you can't catch the ball
with your with your legs it has to be
with your hands but I don't see any
proof here that the ball did hit the
ground so right now I would expect the
call to stand so since it was called a
touchdown on the field I just don't
think there's enough indisputable video
evidence to overturn you have to have
beyond all doubt and Matt like you said
I if this was called incomplete I could
see it also standing but since it was
called a touchdown on the field
not sure I've seen enough to justify it
being overturned well either way let's
just say this Kentucky has something in
game Omarion Knighton lined up all the
way at the top of your screen 29 in
white lettuce look that way looks off
fires over the middle
it's a foot race and it's a Kentucky
touchdown
69 yards to the house Tavion Robinson
[Applause]
or on a bad snap
the drive started with fire from smoke a
27-yard run
and then a 69-yard bomb at 11's no
interceptions tonight but he's thrown
one in four straight
[Applause]
Levis over the middle wide open ground
angling across the 40. that's a big race
to the end zone
touchdown Kentucky the Haymaker
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah barium Brown the super talented
true freshman catching cloud coverage
here just running a basic in cut
will levith putting the ball on the
money
[Applause]
Brown on with a flag still hauling it in
and lavis is injured
Kentucky's fan base holding their
Collective breath after that hard hit on
Levis
[Applause]
it's time let's go
crowd is
and Kentucky knocking on the door again
50-yard gain
you can run it see the pressure come
from the outside watch how early he's
going to let that ball go and the
receiver is expected on the outside but
no one there will ever since the throne
inside their own three
Leathers In The End Zone loads it fire
as far as sideline and a first down at
the 35 to Barry and brown
is they have not been able to get any
big plays since Mississippi State
they've had four 20-yard pass plays and
only one plus 30. and there's a 31 right
there so their second since four games
man-to-man coverage they go right at it
and uh on the 26.
[Applause]
Levis pressure coming going deep got a
man there and got it to him at the 35
and it's Marion brown one of those young
guys Gary just talked about
man in the stack this time gets the
speed oh double break he breaks in then
he broke out and then back in for the
nice throw in a big play remember coming
into this game
getting some pressure but going deep the
ball is wobbling in the air and it's
caught again Barbarian Brown deep shots
this is really the third deep shot that
Kentucky has hit against this George